you see a lot in the stresses will crush
you and then you can also find evidence
that stress will grow you
how should uh we the listeners think
about stress i mean what's the most
adaptive way to think about stress
and should we talk about our stress
should we not talk about our stress
um is there a a short list of of ways
that we can cope with stress better or
may i should be careful with the word
cope is there a way that we can leverage
stress to our advantage great yeah and
that's an important
important nuance in your language which
is people have
by and large come from a place of how do
you manage stress how do you cope with
that which implies
how do you fight against it vacation
massages yoga classes and yeah fight
against
check out exactly right and yeah the
real challenge is how do we leverage it
how do we utilize it how do we work with
it
and yeah i have a lot of thoughts on
this the first and most most important
thing is to
clarify our definition of stress
so i think people often associate
the stress my negative stress mindset is
so
insidious
that now people define stress with its
negative consequences
so the first step is to decouple that
and to realize that stress is a
neutral
right
yet to be determined effect
of experiencing
or anticipating
adversity in your goal-related efforts
so let me unpack that a little more you
can be in the midst of it or you could
just be worried about something
happening that's one aspect second is
adversity or challenge so something
that's working against you but the third
piece is critical and that is in your
goal related efforts
what that means is that we only stress
about things we care about
things that matter to us
so
this is really important right because
stress
is
linked with it's the other side of the
coin of things we care about
right and so i think that's the first
thing to realize right that as humans
we
stress because we care and we
don't stress about things we don't care
about so the simplified example i like
to use is you know if johnny was failing
school
that wouldn't stress you out unless
johnny was your son
or you or johnny or you really cared
about the educating the johnnies of the
world right it only becomes stressful to
the extent that you care about it
so
why are we trying to
fight or run away or hide or merely cope
with our stress or you know overcome it
through our massages when
the stress is connected to the things we
care about
so then the question becomes okay if
that's true how can i better
utilize or leverage or respond to the
inevitable stresses that we're going to
experience
i'm not saying go out and seek out more
stress what i am saying is that you're
going to experience stress if you have
any cares or values or passions and
most all of us do
and so
then what do you do and we've developed
a three-step approach to adopting a
stresses enhancing mindset and briefly
it's the first step is to just
acknowledge that you're stressed to
own it see it
uh be mindful of it
the second step is to welcome it
why would you welcome it you welcome it
because
inherently in that stress is something
you care about so you're using it as an
opportunity to reconnect to
what is it that i care about here and
then the third step is to utilize the
stress response
to achieve the thing you care about
not spend your time money effort energy
trying to get rid of the stress
does that make sense makes sense and i
love it as somebody whose laboratory
studies the physiological effects of
stress the effects that impress me the
most are for instance
the narrowing of visual attention
that it then um drives a capacity to
parse time more finely which then drives
the capacity to process information
faster it's almost like a superpower
right uh and
yes it can feel uncomfortable
often um but i love the idea that
acknowledging it um embracing it and
then understanding its power and
leveraging that power uh i think is in
what i like so much about that framework
is that the stress response is very
generic we unlike the relaxation
response we don't actually have to train
up the stress response so we all kind of
get this as a as a freebie
and then it sounds like it's a question
of what we end up doing with that right
and han seliyer father of stress said
himself it's a non-specific response
right so
it occurs it's what you're doing with it
it's how you're channeling it and yeah
like we talked about before what most
people
do is they stress about the stress which
then over exacerbates it or they check
out from the stress which leads to
depression and anhedonia because by
checking out from stress you're also
checking out from the things we care
about and substance abuse exactly our
colleague anna lemke who also we had the
good fortune of having as a guest on
this podcast talked a lot about this
that you know i mean so much of
substance abuse
because she runs the addiction clinic
over on the
med side of campus um
it
takes over people's lives because of
this
increased ability to to find a solution
to the stress that then eventually
becomes its own stressor and its own
problem
um
well i i love that that mindset and
framework and so i think unique
constraints like the best way to destroy
someone's motivation and productivity
and momentum give them a ton of money
give them a ton of time give them a ton
of freedom
when you have an overabundance of those
things you just start floating in space
because there's no hard line
there's no wall there's no constraint
for you to push up against and and for
that's going to force you to kind of
make a make a choice yeah
yeah this reminds me of something i read
in a business book recently around like
kind of building startups and stuff
where it's kind of the idea that
before a business has figured out their
money printing machine
it's very exhilarating very very like
all hands on deck we need to we need to
make this happen there is a sense of
urgency a sense of energy about the
place as soon as the business has
figured out what its money printing
machine is and now they scale and now
they get more people on board yeah
suddenly you start caring about [ __ ]
things like yeah oh i want everyone to
only be working six hours a day i want
to make sure we have bean bags i want to
make sure we have massages at work and
all this kind of stuff yeah and you
often hear from people that the early
days were in a way more fun than the
scaling days when we had the table
tennis table and the bean bag and all
the perks that you could you could dream
for yes because there is this sense of
urgency when you're like i need to make
this work yeah and once it's working
you're like then it's a lot it's very
easy to just be like oh life is good
that's very true that's the way you want
to live life um but i think there is
then a danger of
you know a lot of big businesses move so
much slower than smaller businesses a
lot of big businesses are at risk of
potentially failing because they don't
have that momentum that
a scrappy startup does absolutely i
think that same kind of principle
applies to our personal lives as well
yeah that there is a level of like
keeping up the scrappiness yeah which is
just generally fun as long as it doesn't
overly burn you out and stress you out
to the point where it's like chronic
over such a long period of time yes but
there is some energy in you know the
idea of hormesis and you know what
doesn't kill you makes you stronger
a little bit of calorie restriction is
good for the body a little bit of sleep
deprivation is good for us a little bit
of like having to run
and like be in a stress situation is
good for us yeah um whereas if we're a
couch potato with a catheter and like a
video game controller all day living a
very comfortable life um then you know
there's not much progress there
[Music]
you